[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JOHN DOLHUN: Good
morning, everyone.
And welcome, or good afternoon.
Welcome to The Ellen Swallow
Richards Lecture Series.
This is our beloved
Charles River.
This is the river you're
going to be testing.
Once you've tested
this river, you
can actually take this
testing and apply it
to any body of water.
Why should we be concerned
about this Charles River?
Yes?
Because we live next to it.
Because we live--
that's a good reason.
Because we live next to it.
Anyone else?
Aisha?
AUDIENCE: To care
about your environment.
JOHN DOLHUN: You care
And speaking of caring
about your environment,
we've got some problems
with phosphate out there.
We've got high phosphorus
concentrations.
And those high
phosphorus concentrations
lead to algal blooms.
And those algal blooms produce
toxic chemicals and odors.
And when all this algae dies,
it heads down to the bottom
and breaks off and it's
acted on by decomposers.
These microbes start
to chew it apart
and they use up the dissolved
oxygen so that we get lower--
lower dissolved
oxygen in the water.
And what that does is
it leads to fish kills.
And our recreational
ability is impaired.
So here are some examples
of what I'm talking about.
This is Florida, 2016.
This is Lake Okeechobee, one of
the largest fresh water lakes
in Florida.
This is a 30 mile
long fish kill.
It involves some
50 species of fish.
The cause, most
probably, an algal bloom,
the result of leaking
septic systems,
fertilizers from lawns
going into the water.
This is an economic disaster.
It's going to take decades
to recover from this.
Is Bradenton, Florida, 2018.
This is their harbor
filled with dead fish.
This started from an algal bloom
that turned into a red tide.
And the red tide
stretched about 150 miles
off the coast of
Florida, and gradually,
the wind and the currents
brought it into shore.
And when that red
tide came in to shore,
it started releasing toxins
into the air and water,
and then the nutrients
broke off and microbes
started digesting them
and used up the oxygen,
and all these fish died.
This is Australia, 2019.
This is the Darling River,
but it also happened in
the [INAUDIBLE] River.
And they had a successive
run of these fish kills,
one right after the other.
Again, it's global
hot temperatures
and agricultural runoff.
This is the Charles
River, August, 2019.
This is the largest
algal bloom, I think,
that we've had out there.
It actually stretched
from the BU bridge
to the Museum of Science.
And cyanobacteria was detected.
This is a health problem.
So we're going to be measuring
phosphorus in the waters
out here.
That's one of the things
we're going to do.
And there are two
types of phosphorus,
there's the inorganic,
which is simply
salts of phosphoric
acid, and then
if you create esters
of the inorganic form,
you have the organic
form of phosphate.
So let's take a
look for a moment
at the inorganic phosphate.
I mean, phosphorus is like,
the 11th most abundant element
on the planet.
And it's not found
in elemental form.
You won't find any pure
phosphorous anywhere
on the Earth.
It's found in these types of
phosphates, in rocks and soils,
and that's how it exists.
So the main inorganic player
here is the orthophosphate.
And that's the PO4
to the 3 minus.
This is the most stable
form of phosphorus.
And this is the form that's
readily available to plants
for uptake by the plants.
I mean, all plants and animals
need phosphorus for growth.
It's the backbone of our
DNA and the Krebs cycle.
Plants need it in
photosynthesis.
They have to extract it
from their environment
because they're not going to
make sugar unless they first
make ATP to actually connect
those bonds in the sugars
that they're making.
So we've got this
orthophosphate, the main player
here, but in the
inorganic category,
you can actually
connect several of these
together and form
a polyphosphate,
such as our detergents.
A lot of detergents
are polyphosphates.
P3O10 to the 5 minus
would be a polyphosphate.
The interesting thing
about the polyphosphates
is as soon as they
hit the water,
they hydrolyze into
the orthophosphate.
And then we've got the
organic phosphates,
which are esters of
the inorganic form.
And organic phosphates are
found in all living tissues.
So all living tissues,
both plants and animals,
have organic phosphates.
And waste is also another form
of the organic phosphates.
So when something living
dies, it starts to decay.
What happens is the
phosphates actually
convert to the orthophosphate.
That's what happens to them.
So this is what we're
going to be measuring.
And now, I'd like to talk
for a few minutes about how
it gets into the water, where
all this stuff is coming from.
So we're going to look at
some of the primary sources
of the phosphorus.
The first one is
storm water runoff.
Can anyone give me an example
of some phosphoruses, phosphates
that can get into the water
from storm water runoff?
Yes, Aisha.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure if
there's a phosphate in dirt.
JOHN DOLHUN: Absolutely.
There's phosphate in the dirt.
And that would get washed in.
What else?
Yes, Jimmy?
AUDIENCE: Probably less
here, but in agriculture,
I'm pretty sure they're
used in fertilizer.
JOHN DOLHUN: Oh, gosh, yes.
Fertilizers are a big
thing because of lawns.
So we've got soil
here and fertilizers.
Anything else?
Jimmy?
AUDIENCE: I guess
animal droppings?
JOHN DOLHUN: Absolutely.
Animal waste.
I mean, think about where
do they put pig farms?
They put them all
by a river, right?
And all those geese, the guano,
droppings, everything, they're
all out there by the river.
And all that stuff
is being washed in.
So animal waste is a
big, big source here.
Anything else?
You ever got your car
washed in a car wash?
Do you ever sit in it
while you're going through,
see all that soap coming down?
Tons of soap.
And all that soap's going
into the sewer systems,
and when it starts to rain,
heavy rains, it bubbles over.
So car washes would
be a big source,
and there's your polyphosphates.
Another one that you might
not be as familiar with
is car exhausts.
Car exhausts have a
catalyst tube in there.
When that tube gets hot,
like 500, 600, 700 degrees,
it can form cerium
phosphate, which is released
in the exhaust effluent.
So cerium phosphate
would be a culprit here.
And then probably
the biggest source
is discharge from
wastewater treatment plants.
Did any of you ever go to tour
a wastewater treatment plant?
Anyone?
Oh, you did?
Kelly, right?
Could you tell us--
tell us about it,
what your experience was?
AUDIENCE: It was a school
fieldtrip a long time ago,
I think.
It was interesting.
So they purified
or treat the water
with several different methods.
On of them was just
like, bacterial,
and then they introduce
it [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah, they
aerate it with bacteria,
I think, in the
secondary treatment.
And they do that to get
rid of organic matter
or to digest it down to sludge.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And then there's a UV method.
JOHN DOLHUN: Very good.
I mean, the most modern plants
have this ultraviolet rays
at the very end.
You can walk along and
you can see a glass floor.
You can see the
water going through
with the ultraviolet
rays hitting it.
And then, at the end,
they have a faucet
and they offer you a drink.
I mean, there was
no one in my group
that availed themself to
take a sip of that water
after going through that.
But let's put this
in perspective.
So wastewater treatment
plants, they're
all built along
rivers or oceans.
And when a heavy rain,
they start to discharge.
They have to discharge.
They can't take the flow.
First thing, they
may discharge some
of the secondary treated water.
Sometimes, they have to
discharge the raw sewage.
But to put it in
perspective, all of us
produce about 2.2
grams of pee per day.
I'm talking about
phosphorus here.
That's about 1.8
pounds per year.
Now, when that phosphorus hits
the sewage treatment plant,
it's in the effluent,
it gets diluted down.
You're talking
somewhere between 2
and probably 20 milligrams
per liter PPM of phosphorous
in the water.
After the secondary
treatment, they only
take out between 1 and
2 milligrams per liter.
So you end up with a
large excess of phosphorus
in the treated water.
So when they release,
it's a ton of phosphorus
hitting the water.
But the good news is--
I'm going to draw a smiley
face here, because the EPA just
filed a regulation forcing--
they're going to force all
these wastewater treatment
plants to cut back, get rid of
the phosphorus in the water,
and they're going
to have to-- they're
going to have to
take it down to less
than 1.0 milligrams per liter.
So all these plants are running
around now trying to figure out
how they're going to do that.
This, I believe, just went
into effect this year,
and may go-- may be
starting in January of 2020,
but there are EPA regulations
that are just coming out.
The other major source
is sewer overflows.
And in New England, everyone--
it's notorious that you have
a sump pump in your basement.
So when your basement
floods, the pump starts up
and it pumps everything.
They're connected to
the sewer systems.
So everything in
the kitchen sink
is going into the sewer
system and it's bubbling over.
So those are the
primary sources.
Now, let's look at
the ecological effect
of all this phosphorus.
This is the Charles River,
the famous Charles River.
This is up by Newton, Mass.
There's a guy in a canoe trying
to pull out the vegetation
out of the water.
What this vegetation
does is two things.
First, it's blocking
the sunlight
to organisms and other plants
down below the surface that
need that sun.
And the second thing is it's
going to die and produce
these swamp-like
odors, and then it's
going to get decomposed
by microorganisms that
are going to use up the oxygen.
This is the result. This
is blue-green algae.
This is really-- another name
for this is cyanobacteria.
It's the cyanobacteria that
give it that green color
on the surface of the water.
Here are some other forms of it.
You can get this pea
soup kind of look,
or you can get this
mossy look, or you
might get a painted look.
The bottom line is
it's all bacteria.
It's unicellular bacteria.
These are prokaryotic bacteria.
They have no nucleus, but
they make their own food
and they secrete chemicals.
These are the same
bacteria, believe it or not,
that gave us life 3.5
billion years ago.
And now, they're out to get us.
Isn't that amazing?
Every time I look at
this, I can't believe it.
I mean, when we had
no oxygen, these
were the guys that were
giving our oxygen atmosphere,
and now, look what
they're doing.
Now, if these are out
there in the water,
you don't want to
go in the water.
If you do, you are dead
meat, and I'll tell you why.
You can have all
kinds of symptoms,
you can get covered
with a rash, you
can have diarrhea, flu-like
symptoms, eye and ear problems,
respiratory problems.
I gave you an
article in the news.
This is The New York Times.
Central Park in New
York, all of their ponds,
infected with blue-green algae.
Here's a good example.
This is today, "Ohio strikes
a Blow in Algae Fight."
This is The Wall Street
Journal this morning.
This article just came out.
Interestingly, Ohio had this
algae problem 10 years ago,
and they took around
one of their lakes
and they built up
these wetland areas
to prevent the runoff
from reaching--
the agricultural runoff
from reaching the lake,
and it's actually working.
So there are ideas
out there that you
can come up with an idea
and solve a problem.
So some of these cyanobacteria,
some of the fresh water
bacteria produce
very toxic chemicals.
One form of these
are the microcystins.
There are something like 50
different micocystins that
have been identified to date.
It's a cyclic peptide here.
And this is a hepatotoxin.
So once this gets through
your skin into your body,
your liver is going
to get attacked,
and you're pretty much gone.
There's not much
you can do about it.
The article mentions the dogs--
one woman had three
dogs in North Carolina.
She let them go for
a swim in a pond.
All three dogs died
within a few hours.
So this is really nasty stuff.
And I challenge you to
think about coming up
with an antidote for this.
There's your startup
company right here.
I'm giving it to you.
When this stuff is active, you
go out to the Charles River,
you'll see these signs posted
warning people and pets
to stay out of the water.
Here's another example.
This is the summer of 2014.
This is a satellite
picture of Lake Erie, one
of the five Great
Lakes in this country.
And the lake actually borders
Canada on one side, separates
Canada from the US near
Ontario, and then there
are several states
that border the lake.
Out here to the west is
Toledo, Ohio, and Toledo,
fourth largest city in
Ohio, has a population
of about a half million.
This was their
tap water in 2014.
And I had a 5.310 student
in class four years ago who
remembers this.
I mean, this is
serious business.
And it's happening all
over, all over the world.
Here's another picture.
This is the largest landlocked
body of water on the Earth.
Anybody from Europe
here recognize this?
What?
Who said that?
Yes, Sean, exactly correct,
that's the Caspian Sea.
It's bordered by five countries.
But look at the massive,
massive algal growth
from this satellite picture.
Here's the Volga River, Europe's
longest river, pouring into it.
It's a 2,000 mile long river.
Here's a new word for
you, eutrophication.
It's from the Greek
meaning well nourished.
So how much phosphorus
is acceptable?
The EPA came out in 2000--
that was almost 20 years ago--
and said 0.0238
milligrams per liter.
Well, we know today that
if you have anything
greater than or equal to
0.016 milligrams per liter,
you're going to have
really a large algal growth
proliferating in your water.
Now, these concentrations
of phosphorus, they're low.
And it's going to be
challenging to measure those.
This is what we're going to do.
The other thing that
makes it challenging
is phosphates are colorless.
So how are we going to
use UV vis to measure
these concentrations?
Anybody have an idea?
Yes?
Maybe we can react
them with something
that will make them colorful?
Maybe we can react
them with something
that can make them colorful.
Very good.
Yeah, I like that.
Keisha, right?
AUDIENCE: Gizelle.
JOHN DOLHUN: Gizelle.
I'm sorry, Gizelle.
Where's Keisha?
There she is.
OK.
All right, so react
them with something
that makes it colorful.
So here comes chemistry
to the rescue, right?
So phosphates are very reactive.
So we can actually take river
water and this method here,
this is the ammonium
metavanadate method.
When I tried to develop this
Charles River water testing,
I started with this
method because it
was written up as the
method to detect phosphorus
in river water.
So you would take
the river water,
mix it with molybdate,
ammonium metavanadate,
and you create this color
heteropoly molybdic acid
that has a yellow color
and it absorbs light
at 400 nanometers.
What I found is that this
method was not sensitive enough
to actually measure
the phosphorus
levels in the Charles River.
It's a great method for
measuring phosphorus in sewage,
but not the rivers.
So I looked around
and I found what's
called the ascorbic acid method,
an EPA-approved method where
you actually took
river water, mixed it
with molybdate,
sulfuric acid, and you
create this heteropoly molybdic
acid, which is colorless.
But the good thing is this
heteropoly molybdate anion
can accept electrons
and be reduced down
and ascorbic acid can
cause that reduction.
And you end up getting this
molybdenum blue complex,
a mixed valence complex
that absorbs light
at 880 nanometers.
So this is great because
the concentration
of the phosphorus
in the complexes
is proportional
to the absorbance
of the light in these things.
So this is what you're
actually making.
It's beautiful.
This is a Keggin structure.
It captures the phosphorus in
the center, surrounded by 12
molybdenums and 40 oxygens.
I want you to take a
moment and look at this.
And I'd like you all to
close your eyes for a moment
and think about this image.
Close your eyes.
OK, open your eyes, please.
I want you to carry
this image with you
into the lab when you
do this experiment.
You're actually going to be
making this in your beakers
when you add the color
developer to your water samples.
You're creating this in about
15 minutes in your beaker.
This is inorganic
chemistry at its best.
Now, I want to spend the next
several slides showing you
how we're going to
actually measure
the concentrations of this.
So we're going to be shining
electromagnetic energy
on a sample.
And if you look at
the visible light
here that I broke out of this
electromagnetic spectrum,
on the red end of
this, we're going
to be looking at our
samples on that far red end
in the near IR.
So that's where
you're going to be--
where you're going to
be taking your readings.
Now, what can happen when you
shine radiation on your sample?
Anyone?
Yes, Kim.
AUDIENCE: Photobleaching
JOHN DOLHUN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Some of your sample
could get photobleached.
JOHN DOLHUN: Some of your sample
could get photobleached, yeah.
That's a possibility.
What else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Exactly.
I mean, electrons
could get chewed up
to a higher energy levels.
Little nuclei could see
that happen and get nervous
and start to
rearrange themselves.
And the molecule, as Kelly said,
could burst into vibration.
And your UV is
actually monitoring
all of those electronic
transmissions
that we can't see with our eye.
And what the UV does is it draws
you a smooth curve through all
of those electronic transitions
and you end up somewhere
with your lambda max.
What UV vis is,
a good definition
is it's just the interaction
of light with matter
as a function of wavelength.
So here's your UV cuvette.
Here's the radiation
hitting that cuvette.
What happens?
What do you see up
there happening?
Yes, Ryan?
Yeah, the lights focused.
And what's happening
to the sample?
I'm sure it's heating up, yeah.
Yes, Autumn?
AUDIENCE: It absorbs sunlight
and transmits sunlight and also
re-emits.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah, good.
So some of the
light's going through
and some's getting absorbed.
So let's look at
that for a minute.
So we've got absorbance
minus the log
of the transmitted light,
which is i over i0.
Now, absorbance
is-- we're actually
monitoring the absorbance.
We're not monitoring
the transmittance
because absorbance
is actually directly
proportional to
concentration by Beer's law.
So we have this relationship.
And E, the extinction
coefficient,
is the molar
absorptivity constant,
is simply the amount of
light absorbed per unit
concentration of your sample.
Let me just rewrite this.
Let me get rid of the logarithm.
I want to show you
something here.
So I'm going to rewrite this.
Let's actually
graph the intensity
of the incoming radiation here.
We're going to graph that as
a function of concentration.
If you do that, you're going
to see from that equation
that the transmitted light
decreases exponentially
as the concentration increases.
I want you to keep that
in the back of your mind.
This equation fascinated me.
I like Beer's law.
What this tells you, this
extinction coefficient
tells you, that it
has to be a constant.
So if you cut your
concentration in half,
absorption should
be cut in half.
So I wanted to prove this.
So I went out and I
made this compound,
hexacyanoferrate(III).
And I made up five
solutions of this,
and then I measured the
absorbance of each solution.
It absorbed light
at 420 nanometers.
And if you look here, 10
times e to the minus 4,
if I cut that in half to 5
times e to the minus 4, indeed,
the absorption gets cut
in half as it should.
So I graph this, got
a nice, straight line.
The change in absorption over
the change in concentration
is my slope.
And it's 1,056.7 so that's
my extinction coefficient.
And this worked really well.
But I want to caution you--
if you try this, and
you're graphing absorption
versus concentration, and
you're doing Beer's law,
you've got this
nice, straight line,
you might end up with
something like this,
where Beer's law falls apart.
And it all comes
back to this here--
the intensity of the
transmitted light
decreases exponentially
with concentration.
So eventually, if the
concentration is too high
your sample becomes
saturated, and you're not
going to be-- this
Beer's law falls apart.
I just want you to
be aware of that.
What I did is I made up all of
my concentrations are very low.
Beer's law worked fine.
So now we're going to get
to some serious business.
This is what you have to do
for this lab, for it to work.
Otherwise, you will be a goner--
gonzo.
You've got to clean
this glassware.
This is a list of the glassware
that you'll need to clean.
And you've got to do it with
10% hydrochloric acid, triple
rinsed with Milli-Q Water.
Why do you think
you need to do that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Any contamination
might change the products
concentration.
JOHN DOLHUN: Any
contamination is going
to just destroy the experiment.
It's kind of like
the Nano Building.
You've seen them in there
with their bunny suits on.
One speck of dust, even
a dander from your hair,
is like a wrecking
ball to the experiment.
Well, one speck of
phosphate from any detergent
is going to wreck
this experiment.
So you've got to
judiciously sit down.
There'll be two of you-- you'll
be partnered up for this.
So you clean this up.
And you'll do this on day two
after the dissolved oxygen
testing.
This is what you're
going to need
for day three for the
phosphate testing.
So you can leave this
glassware in the top drawer
above your locker.
It's not locked.
And it'll be nice
and ready for when
you come in to do the testing.
So this is what you
have to do in this lab.
First of all, we need to
make up a set of standards
that we can
interpolate our river
samples against to find the
concentrations of the phosphate
and phosphorus.
So you're going to make
seven standards up.
And you're going to be
using a stock solution.
And the formula to use
in all these tables
is you're going to use
this M1V1 equals M2V2.
So if you have a 10 to the
minus 1/3 molar stock solution,
and you're taking 1 milliliter
of it out, out of the bottle,
how much molarity
do you want to make
to make up 100 mil solution?
You'll be diluting
this 1 mil to 100,
and you'll see that your
x is 10 to the minus 5.
That's your stock
solution of phosphate
that you're going to create.
So you just use that
formula for all these.
You're taking this
much out of your 10
to the minus 5 molar
stock solution,
and you're diluting
it up to 10 mils.
What's my concentration?
Perfect.
What you'll do is you'll
come into the lab,
and the TAs will go
through this with you.
You'll make up your
stock solutions.
And then you'll go to the
river to get your water.
And when you bring the
water back to the lab,
there'll be two of you.
So one of you will
go over to the hoods
and get the color developer.
And these are the four
chemicals that we talked about
in the color developer--
the ammonium molybdate,
sulfuric acid, ascorbic acid,
potassium antimonyl-tartrate.
Potassium antimonyl-tartrate
is there to actually speed up
the reduction that's going
on with ascorbic acid.
That's important.
If I didn't mention that before,
that's the purpose of that.
The ammonium molybdate,
sulfuric acid,
you're creating that
Keggin structure,
that heteropoly,
colorless, molybdic acid.
You also have to take this
color developer in the order
that it's written here.
It'll be set up in
burettes in the hood.
If you, for example,
take it in a wrong order,
you could have a side
reaction, and not
get the color developer that
you want to put in your sample.
So it's important.
So one of you will go to the
hood, get the color developer.
The other one will go to the
river water you brought back,
use a clean pipette,
10 mL pipette,
and pipette five beakers
with river water, five
10-mL beakers.
So you'll end up with 12-- seven
standards and five samples.
And then you add
the color developer,
and you wait 20 minutes,
and you're ready to go.
Just a couple other precautions
that you should take--
we're going to be
using 4-mL cuvettes.
These are big inside.
Don't use the 1 and
1/2 mL cuvettes.
The other thing is all these
cuvettes have a fill line.
It becomes frosted at one point.
And you want to stop pouring
when you get to that line.
You're going to
take your beakers,
and you're going to
swirl them gently.
And you're going to
pour them by hand
until you reach the fill line.
Don't go beyond that.
Also, all of these UV cuvettes
have an arrow on one side.
You want to be sure
that the arrow is
in the light beam when you
put these cuvettes in the UV
spectrometer.
A lot of people
have made mistakes,
put them in the wrong
way, and then you're
not going to get
very good readings.
So the arrow's clear to see.
What I usually do is
arrange all my cuvettes
in a box ahead of time.
And then I pour my samples
and put them in the box,
and I know the arrow's
in the right place.
And when I go to the UV, I just
lift them up and put them in.
Also, keep in mind what
Dr. Sarah Hewett told you
the other day that there's two
kinds of pipettes in the lab.
This one is a blowout pipette.
You've got to blow it all
out to get your 10 mLs.
This one is a to
deliver pipette.
You only go up to
that last line.
You don't blow the tip in,
otherwise you put too much--
going to wreck your experiment.
So make sure you look at
the pipettes carefully.
So you're going to get your
graph here, a nice graph.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to interpolate
now your river
absorbances against the
curve so you can read off
the concentrations.
So the concentrations in
that graph are in micromolar.
So you're going to want
to take those and convert
them to milligrams per liter.
So you want to
convert this first
to a molarity, moles per liter.
Then you take that, and you want
to go down to grams per liter,
and then finally
milligrams per liter.
So you're going to be
calculating two things.
You want to calculate the
phosphate concentration in ppm,
which is milligrams per
liter, and the phosphorus
concentration.
So you'll take your mass
from the curve in milligrams
per liter, and take it times
the ratio for phosphate of PO4
over KH2PO4.
And that ratio is 0.70.
And then for phosphorus,
do the same thing.
The ratio there is 0.23.
And this is the most
important part of this lab--
this is the whole
thing, calculating
these concentrations in the end.
So it's important to
know how to do that.
So once you get
your concentrations,
you've got a series of
things to go through here
for your data analysis.
There's no error propagation
on this part of the lab, which
is good for you.
You will have to use
the LINEST equation
that Sarah talked about,
which is pretty easy to use.
And that'll help you calculate
the errors of your slope
intercept and y values.
And then you find your
average and standard deviation
of the five measurements,
calculate the 95% confidence
interval.
Most importantly, report
the final concentration
of P and PO4.
Make sure all these results
show up in your abstract.
First thing I do when
I get lab reports is I
look at the abstract.
I want to see a line
that shows my results.
And they also should
appear in your conclusion,
and then you can discuss them
in your discussion of your lab
report.
So any questions about this?
I know you're going to have
a busy weekend because you're
going to be working on your
ferrocene lab, your first lab
report.
And I want to tell
you that please,
feel free to reach
out to me or Sarah
if you have any questions.
I'm going to be here tomorrow.
I probably will be here
Saturday and Sunday.
So if there's a last
minute question,
just send me an email, and
I'm happy to invite you in,
and we can answer your question.
I should be here in the
afternoon, probably,
on Saturday and Sunday.
Now, I'd like to end the lecture
today by doing a demonstration.
Actually, did I turn that off?
I can show you this here.
I'm going to do this
Briggs-Rauscher reaction.
Actually, we're going to
make this iodomalonic acid.
We're going to actually attach
an iodine to malonic acid.
We're going to create
this in a beaker.
The reason I'm showing
you this reaction
is because it has everything
in it, including starch.
And it has a lot of colors.
And these colors are
things that we're
going to talk about in the
next lecture, what starch does
and how it works.
And this is kind of
a preview to that.
This reaction that
you're going to see
was actually discovered by two
high school chemistry teachers.
They're Briggs and Rauscher
from Galileo High School,
my favorite city, San Francisco.
So these guys came up with
this back in, I think, 1973.
They published a paper in the
Journal of Chemical Education.
And they had every scientist
in the country puzzled.
And it took about
10 years to work out
all the and sundry
reactions that
are going on in this reaction.
So I'm going to put on
some safety glasses.
And what I'm going
to be doing is
going to be mixing three
colorless solutions in here.
This is my first one.
And I'm going to use
kitchen chemistry, which
means I'm kind of looking
at that scale over there
and I'm going to pour these in.
So let's put a little more.
That's colorless, right?
OK, next colorless solution.
That's about right.
And the final colorless
solution-- keep your eye on it.
Oh my goodness, wow.
It wasn't supposed to do that.
What?
Are you kidding me?
What's going on here?
Get your clock out.
This is a clock reaction.
You can keep time with this.
So I'll give you a little hint.
There iodide in there, I minus.
And I minus is colorless.
There is iodine in there,
and iodine is amber.
When they're both
present, it's blue-black.
And we're going to see why
that is in the next lecture.
So there's a lot of
reactions going on in there.
When these reactants react,
they form hypoiodous acid.
And sometimes, the
hypoiodous acid actually
oxidizes iodide to iodine.
So you've got collarless
going to amber.
But sometimes, there's so
much hypoiodous acid formed,
you can't handle everything.
And what happens is you
have a little bit of I
minus and I2 present
at the same time.
And you get blue-black.
This is kind of the
color you're going
to get when you
do your titrations
and you add the
starch, because there
is starch present in this.
So I'm going to
leave you with that.
And I'll see some of
you up in the lab.
Yes, you have a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: She just asked
me if this will ever stop.
Can someone--
Hannah wants to know
if this is going to ever stop.
Who can tell me, anyone?
Aisha?
AUDIENCE: I feel like it won't,
because it's not releasing gas.
JOHN DOLHUN: Aisha says it
probably won't because it's not
releasing gas.
But in a minute, it's going to.
Iodine vapor is going to
start pouring out of it,
and Tristan is going to carry
it up to the lab in a bucket
quickly.
But in answer to Hannah's
question is, will this stop?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Limiting
reagent, right?
There's always a
limiting reagent.
OK, see you.